there are three essential elements to an
outstanding film performance a good
script a good director and a magnificent
actor and the five magnificent artists
nominated this year for Best Actor in a
leading role are Roberto Benigni in life
is beautiful Tom Hanks in Saving Private
Ryan Ian McKellen in gods and monsters
[Applause]
Nick Nolte in affliction
[Applause]
Edward Norton in American History X
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Roberto Benigni in
life
[Applause]
is the first after
therefore performance in a
almost 40 years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a terrible mistake because I
used up all my English what I sow okay
now I am not able to express all my
gratitude because now we say my body is
in tumult because it's a colossal moment
of joy so everything is really in any in
any way that I cannot express I would
hate to be Jupiter and kidnap everybody
and lie down in the firmament making
love with everybody because I don't know
how to express it's a question of laughs
you are really this is among kind of
snow so dedicated to the suavity and the
kindness and is something I cannot
forget from the bottom of my heart and
thank you for the Academy Awards for the
who really loved the movie thank you to
all the in Italy for the Italian cinema
Gracie Alitalia who made me I am really
they III owe to them all my if I did
something good so grazie Alitalia a
Graciela miracle and a lot of things
here thank you very much and I hope
really I don't deserve a day sir but I
hope to win the some others Oscars thank
you
[Music]
last year